the question was the answer is obvious
so can I just write it down is there a
reason why I can't just write down that
it's going to be five and ten right
because I convince Alesi five or ten out
250 and 10 square plus y square is a
hundred twenty-five so can I just do
that right and answer is no if I set
this question to you as an exam set up
what am I trying to assess what am I
looking for yeah thank you yeah the
ability to use one of these techniques
in order to solve this question I'm
looking for the technique I don't care
what the values are I'm looking to see
that you can show me how to get to those
values okay so therefore it's actually
the process the answer down at the very
end it might be worth like one mark out
of three but not the lion's share of
what I'm actually looking for okay now i
will give a caveat to that suppose this
is not the exact question suppose the
actual question was something else and
in the process of solving that question
you arrive here and you're like now i
have to solve these okay now this is a
totally different scenario okay if I
gave you some different questions to
begin with and then this was a necessary
step along the way then what I'm trying
to assess might be something else okay
for instance can you interpret this
paragraph of text that I've given you
which should lead you to these equations
and that can you solve in that case I've
assessing different things right and so
I'll place less emphasis on this in a
similar way to how if you get given a
circle geometry proof in an agency
extension one or extension to exam I'm
not mainly looking for you to prove
similar triangles even if civil
triangles I needed in the proof I'm
looking for you to recognize circle
properties and put them together in the
right way and right into dr. geometry
proof so do you have the similarity
proof they're perfectly with all the
five lines maybe maybe not that's all
I'm focused on does that make sense is
it's a tricky answer that's why it's
kind of like it's yes or no but for this
question it's definitely yes
okay now be that this has a quadratic
unit there is clearly one method that's
going to be better which way should we
go substitution so you've got equation
one and equation two right we're the
equation why you should rearrange it you
can isolate whichever one you want this
is a symmetrical pair of equations
there's no clear benefit to isolating X
or isolated wine but i'll just point out
to you that sometimes there is have a
look at what you'll be substituting into
and think about making this as simple as
you can in this case it doesn't matter
which one okay but sometimes it does i'm
going to eliminate Y so I make y equal
to that and I'll substitute that into
two okay so I've got here x squared plus
15 minus X or squared equals 125 okay no
worries I've reduced my earlier problem
down to one we've looked at before these
quadratic measures with this video a
couple of days on so i've got x squared
2 8530 X I've got another x squared
there that's what I've got let's
simplify out a little bit
is that check out so far yeah clearly I
I've got all even coefficients here so
i'm going to divide through okay and now
just like you suspected before right
when you factorize sure enough you've
got the two years as you were expecting
okay x equals 5 or 10 side but before we
were looking at these equations in x and
y right and so you had x equals to
something and y is equal to something
else okay now this is an important point
this x and y they must exist together
okay they must exist at the same time
but these two values cannot exist at the
same time if i tell you i have a number
X right it can't be five and ten at the
same time simultaneously right it's one
or it's the other okay so therefore you
write at all here and an end here this
is a pair right these guys are kind of
like two different situations just like
before once you got your ex's your wise
need to follow suit okay so you take
your x values that correspond to that so
if x is equal to five then y is equal to
10 or 5 now that's a bit of a messy way
to write it especially if there's more
values trailing off to this so i think
it's kind of safe to say x equals 5 and
y equals 10 that's one pair just like we
had before or x equals 10 and 1 equals 5
and that's just what you lays it out
really really clearly okay right now why
not ask you to get your laptops out
please open a browser for be and where
I'd like you to go is um this address
come now if you have never seen this
before you need to book market because
it is an enormously useful tool it will
save you hours and hours and hours of
time open up a browser and when you go
there you want to see this decisive is a
graphic piece of software okay many of
you with you the school night ops you've
got a piece of software called geogebra
on it which does some of the things that
this does and some different things set
it up it's not a complete overlap
between them but I really like this tool
for a variety of reasons I'm sure Jeff
is great for different purposes we're
graphing we have functions this is a
place to go so go ahead and click the
big red button to launch the calculator
and then up will come this website you
should see a arm a grid there in front
of you okay now by the way I say you
should book market you should bookmark
this not that because this will just say
you'll click you just go straight there
now what I'm going to show you is what
we did here in taking this simultaneous
pair of a credit and then we converted
it into a different problem and then we
solved it but week we're contending that
it's got the same pair of solutions okay
what does that mean think back here do
you remember we were looking at our
extraneous solutions a few days back and
I think from memory the question you
were trying to solve was this right and
the answer was no solution okay and I
suggested to you before you appeal to
algebra is you just called sorry that's
a touch bit too doesn't matter we've
been the same you should just picture it
right and these are two lines that are
parallel they never met ok so the same
way that I asked you to picture that I'm
going to ask you to picture 8 what are
these firstly what's this guy it's a
straight line what's this guy it's a
circle ok now you could go ahead and you
could graph it if you like but baby you
have tools like this available to you
and the question was not graph we're
just going to use graph to understand it
better right use a tool like this ok so
all you have to do is take your
equations and literally your cursor
should already be up here you're going
to list out i'm going to list out a
bunch of equations over here you just
have to type it x plus y equals 16 and
it will come to life before your eyes ok
now if yours is like my your scale
starts off like this excess y equals 15
has intercepts at X intercepts of 15
wine in step 2 15 so you can't really
see it so if you scroll and zoom out you
should actually see your line there it
is ok X plus y
then I want to put this other graph
order here this circle that you were
telling me about okay so come back to
where you put in that first equation XY
equals 15 to get a new equation all you
have to do is head in time okay now in
order to do these indices the quickest
way to do it all right on the border
then i'll type it i'm going to write it
because when i type it'll go by really
quickly the shorthand notation for
powers for indices is there is the Hat
it's above the six so if you go x hat
too if that's what you actually type
okay it's above six right yeah six yeah
plus y hat two equals 125 you will see
it will automatically convert that into
index notation for you okay so I'll go X
hat too right there's x squared as you'd
expect but then I'm going to slap plus y
squared and then it's saying I'm not
ready yet I need you need to tell me
what this is equal to because I don't
have a radius here so that you just have
to say equals 125 and there is the
circle that you would tell you that
earlier okay anna liam veuve this a
little easier so you can see what's good
okay so what was the initial question
the initial question was where is this
straight line intersect with this circle
and sure enough you can see the
solutions that you came up with right
have a look at this first one it's x
equals 5 and y equals 10 that's one pen
and its corresponding pair x equals 10
and y equals 5 okay but then what do we
do algebraically we did all this
manipulation but what did that translate
to visually right well by substitution
we turn us sorry we took a straight line
and a circle into what is this thing
what are we working with you
this is this is a quadratic which is a
parabola isn't it right so in fact I can
take a lot I can take this line or I can
take this line I don't take a slow just
for the sake of it I'm going to go back
to my equation here press ENTER to get a
new one and I'm going to punch in x
squared minus 15x plus 50 right again
use that hat x squared okay what have
you got what can you see x squared minus
15x plus 50 did I input it correctly now
in substituting them I then where's Trey
soul when's it equal to 0 I was looking
for the roots of this quadratic okay
look at the roots right can you see why
they're important and how they
correspond to original question the
roots of this quadratic over here right
line up exactly with the solutions that
I was looking for before can you see
that right now think about this right
you can apply this to all kinds of other
things if it's a quadratic that's why
I'm expecting a quadratic has two
solutions doesn't it has two solutions
every time or does it what other kinds
of choices can I have for a quadratic I
could have no solution what would that
mean for this line this line at the
moment it's called a secant it
intersects with the circle twice right
if the quadratic that I ended up with
had no solutions what would that mean
about my original care of 60 situations
here so just to illustrate if I have a
line going over here right the line the
circle never intersect so the quadrate
that represents their points of
intersection shouldn't have any
solutions right could have two solutions
the quadratic could have no solutions
there's one other choice could have one
solution what would that mean for you
even question it would mean that our
straight line is tangent to a circle
because there's one solution or if you
want to put another way there's a double
solution to pair solutions at the same
point okay so like I said before I mean
what was the point of this it was to
illustrate the fact that all this
algebraic stuff it means something
visually and you should try to move
towards seeing
you've done right don't get lost in all
the algebra rec'd you guys okay what I'm
actually doing is I'm converting the
problem this problem into another
problem that I already know how to solve